blackrock blackrock blackrock de la crau
lacroix france
[Musique]
blackrock à porte ouverte à l'elysée oui
il ne cesse de rencontre emmanuel macron
le premier ministre le ministre de
l'économie
7 au pire un scandale au mieux une
incroyable maladresse
c'est une preuve d'un amateurisme de la
part du gouvernement est en train de
mélanger des choses qui n'ont absolument
rien à voir
blackrock est un gestionnaire d'actifs
et ne s'occupe pas des retraites qu'ils
pensaient
[Musique]
c'est vrai parce que nous avons beaucoup
de clients qui nous ont fait confiance
notamment pour gérer leur retraite pour
quand nous investissons à peu près à
trois cartes de ces 5 milliards est
confiée pour la gestion de la retraite
[Musique]
si votre réforme à son terme les
affaires de blackrock rendront donc un
formidable essor en france les 300000
plus hauts revenus de notre pays
n'auront pas d'autre choix que de se
tourner vers un système d'assurance
privée
[Musique]